okay thank you yeah okay are you on the
other line
hello graeme hello
is it jackie weaver
does she have no authority
what's your name what's your name my
name's gail gail lovely
and what have you won lots of prizes for
gail
oh it's not me it's miss my youngest
sonny's he used to play football and do
cross-country he's very good isn't he
yeah yeah okay gail off to go with your
story
okay so just to set the scene we're
talking 25 maybe 26 years ago
when my youngest son was in reception
school
and they were starting to learn how to
spell some words
so the teacher was making it quite easy
by going through the alphabet
and doing very small words and they get
to w
and as you know there's not very many
small words with w but you can spell
so after a couple of words she says okay
we'll make it a little bit harder and
we'll put another letter with the w
and she said we're her so my son and up
straight away
miss miss miss i've got a word should
call and andrew what is it
whip oh she's just very good that's a
nice word yes
my mum's got to whip oh actually andrew
okay yes
it's upstairs in the bedroom okay andrew
that's fine
just some handcuffs as well so when they
come out and told me i said to him did
you ask him though
what the whip was and what the handcuffs
were she says no i didn't go there
so i said we do have whip i said but it
was somebody bought
us in the 80s they'd been to a ball
fight in spain and it was one of them
cheap tacky
souvenir things that they brought back
and then the handcuffs
were some proper handcuffs but they'd
lost the keys for them
and my eldest philip got stuck in them
so to make sure they didn't get stuck in
them again i threw on top of the
wardrobe and that was why they were up
there
it was really really innocent at the end
of the day i'll let you walk i'll let
you walk there you go
yeah um no i i i couldn't i couldn't
flip
flip you for gail anyone else think the
word beginning with w was going to be
wank
yes
no i was so surprised when we got to
whip i was like oh oh
she asked for a long word so i thought
it was gonna be i can't even say it
oh that's right a wanker yeah that's
what i thought
that's our face hello sir what's your
name hi graeme my name's darren
darren we have high hopes to you darren
uh this is david tennant you're hoping
to
hi david tennant in the chair do me
proud and uh where are you darren
i'm in uh queensland australia yeah
excellent
very good and what do you do there uh
well i wasn't
a sheriff but i'm uh i got a heart
condition so i'm now
a uh disability pension at the moment oh
wow that's a
already that's a story it's already a
story okay
off you go with your story darren okay
so um a few years ago we were going to a
new year's eve party
and it was 8 o'clock at night and i had
a bit of time on my hands so
i had a couple of um model planes and
cars that needed fixing so i decided
that
i had a bit of time go and do it so uh
grabbed some super glue went into the
living room started gluing did one or
two models and then i dropped the lid of
the super glue bottle
under the table so i figured that i
could put my hand under the table so as
i was reaching for the thing
i grabbed the lid after a couple of
attempts
and i was like i've got the leaves and
anyway i stuck my head to the um to the
table
so i stuck my forehead move my head to
the table
[Applause]
um
four hours at the hospital and um with a
table came in and said
uh you know i'm doctor such and such um
you know
how can i help you and i'm saying i've
got a coffee table
[Applause]
hello hello what's your name sir it's
mike
mike mike i really hope you have
children mike
how did they find him well funny story
um where are you mike uh in the west
midlands by warsaw
okay keep it vague and um and what what
do you do mike
i work in human resources okay very good
uh so
ramesh mike mike ramesh off you go with
your story
good luck mike thank you so about 14
years ago as
a surprise to my then wife to be i wrote
to one of your guests
who well she was a massive fan of asking
them if they would be kind enough to
send me a good look message
that i could incorporate in my wedding
speech
kindly responded and sent me this
with a message mike's a lucky man
lots of love hugh thank you
to hugh for sending this i mean we're
divorced now
but yeah turns out my glasses are lucky
you can walk yeah they were obviously
married for a long time because
you looked like a child in that picture
that was very good
what a nice thing to do most don't like
me i must have a very efficient
assistant hello graham how are you i'm
very well where are you
in buffalo new york usa oh marvelous and
what's your name
chris chris is that art on the wall
are you planning a project no my wife
and i just moved into a new house
and we'd like to paint the room those
are swatches of
potential colors i'd go
second from i would actually i agree
yes second second from the right i think
that'll all make the room feel smaller
[Laughter]
you need light it's a bedroom they want
it to be cozy it'll be lovely
anyway chris mel generator i believe is
ready in the chair there she is
mel meet chris chris meet mel chris okay
chris your blender is safe okay off you
go he's gonna try and keep you safe
okay come on chris when i was in college
i was dating a girl
whose parents were very good friends
with my parents okay
and both of our parents were very
religious people
right well one weekend our parents were
out at some type of religious meeting
i was over at her house and as people
our eggs do we're on the couch
our clothes came off except for my socks
and all of a sudden we heard the garage
door open
and she gets up she grabs all her
clothes and she runs upstairs
to recompose herself i'm standing there
with no clothes on except
socks my clothes are on the floor i
reach down
put on my shirt and then i realize i
don't have time to put my pants on
so i grab my pants i throw them
underneath me
sit down on the couch and there's a
blanket draped across the couch behind
me
spread the blanket throw it over my lap
cover up the best i could sure enough
the door from the garage
uh opens and opens right
this the up just not that long i mean
it's just
i mean i know this is buffalo new york
but he may have seen the show
are you okay mel that's that's not been
good have you wet yourself i've slightly
wet myself
oh well the show's the show's over we'll
we'll just put some papers down in the
cab and send you home
hello hello hi what's your name
uh nichola nicola and where are you
nichola
i'm enslaved in lincolnshire
lincolnshire home of the internet
okay and uh what do you do there
i'm a primary school teacher oh sauls
you win some you lose some okay
off you go with the story to keep
robbing the chair okay so
i was in mombasa and i had violent
diarrhea
um so i needed to find a toilet oh
is that the end of the story because
that's already a very good
you can't come back from violent
diarrhoea that's the only challenge
i can i um i needed a toilet and the
only toilets i could find in the area
were a hole in the ground
it was a tiled hole with a flush lovely
so
i hovered over the hole my entire body
exploded into the hole
um i flushed and everything that just
exploded from my body came
up from the hole
disgusting she's in charge of children
hello hi happy new year and the same to
you what's your name
nina nina meet nish nish nina nina good
to see you
and uh where are you nina i'm in
washington ireland county waterford
oh lovely lovely lovely and what do you
do in watford
i'm a pediatric nurse a pediatric you
can't flip a story
you can't flip a nurse's story graeme
i'll be the judge of that off you go
nino
okay so it was new year's eve and there
was a party in our local ga club
and i was a student nurse very student i
was just a couple of months into my
training
and a phone call came that a guy had
come off his motorbike down in the
village
so the lads came over like nina can you
help will you go and help and go and
take a look and i'm like
oh i'm very junior but i'll go and have
a look so
we went down and we hopped out of the
car ran over
the guys on one side of the road the
motorbike's on the other side and i
kneeled down next to him
and he's going ah and i said are you
okay are you okay and he's going
and i said hold on now are you hurt oh
and i said right
you have to calm down and be quiet and
tell me exactly where you're hurt
and he goes you're kneeling on my hand
you can walk you can walk peanuts yay
there i wonder hello hi hi you look like
you
you know what you're doing um i hope so
okay what's your name
yasmina yasmina and uh what what
you have an interesting job yes mina
what is it i'm nutritionist
oh how did i know that oh i don't know
if that is interesting but anyway uh
you're a nutritionist
yes arson questions yeah mars bars good
bad
bars or not no no
very bad see do you know each other
she's wrong
do you know okay and uh where are you
from
london okay london nutritionist
sport or company not sport no just um um
on my own i'm a freelance um so he's a
rogue nutritionist
you know they're out there okay off we
go with this story
so this was um my first my first job
when i was in marketing
first few weeks and i had a boss that
was um very prim
proper always wearing a suit very
serious we didn't have a very good
relationship
and he comes in and he's talking to
someone else in the office and i noticed
something is hanging
from the back of his suit it's something
long and white and i'm thinking what and
i'm not quite sure so
i i look closer and i notice it's toilet
paper
he had literally just a little like a
tail a short tail of toilet paper
and at this stage at this point i'm
looking over to my right and
my really close friend of mine is
sitting next to me
and i see in her eyes that she's noticed
at
the same time as me that it's toilet
paper
yes and so i'm i'm i'm i
i just want to burst out laughing
because i can't he's my boss
yes i'm i'm i'm just trying to control
myself trying to
think sad thoughts and not say it not
say anything
and then i think this poor man i have
two choices i don't say anything
and he walks around all day long yes
with this hanging
or i say or i'm decent and i say
something
i know i'm like i was like i was trying
so hard
but that is nearly important ago we do
have time
to visit the big red chair can you smell
the disinfectant
there's like sheep dip back there
who's up first hello hi hi
hi what's your name uh jess jess lovely
and uh where are you from jess um i'm
from melbourne australia melbourne
australia
jess just because this might be on
television i think you'll regret
your jumper gene
[Laughter]
i mean it's humiliating enough without
that added on
uh and do you live here now jess yeah
yeah olivia after last year
okay and what do you do i'm a physio i
fit such a good job
raped are you back are you able to be a
physio yeah yeah i work at the nhs so
oh yeah right yes all the time yeah all
the time yeah yeah non-stop physio
yeah okay jess off you go with your look
oh look at your hands
clutching the nice oh no no i would hang
on
i'm ruining my desk okay
off you go with the storage um so back
when i was a physio in melbourne
i was working on a urology ward with a
patient that had had
surgery on his sort of nether regions so
he had quite swollen testicles
and it was my job to get him up and get
him out of bed and i was in a bit of a
rush
so i went over got him sitting on the
edge and he was a big guy and the gowns
of one size fits all so didn't really
fit him that well
um so he's sitting on the edge i was
like all right let's go and he's like oh
i want to walk in my shoes and i was
like okay where's your shoes and he's
like
underneath the bed oh and so me
being young and stupid decided that i'd
reach for the shoes while he's sitting
on the edge of the bed
and i happened to be between his legs so
as i was reaching to grab the shoes
between his legs i turned my head but
the poor guy had a spasm of pain and
stood up so i ended up with a big
swollen testicle smacking me straight in
you may walk
oh first week back
poro hello
hello hi what's your name linda linda
lovely and uh where are you from linda
rams guy in kent
ramsgate in kent and what do you do
there linda
uh insurance insurance yeah it's very
dangerous
in ramsgate yeah you need insurance
taking out insurance for this oh yes of
course
yeah yeah yeah maybe that's what she's
doing it to make a claim yeah
she'll own the studio off you go with
the story linda
okay right so a few years ago quite a
few years ago um i had a boyfriend
and um he was having a little bit of a
kiss in a cuddle
but at the time i had a quite a large
coleslaw on
lip oh linda you delight me
anyway so after the little kiss and
cuddle i i said to him i said oh
the scabs come off he went yeah i've
just swallowed it
[Applause]
i need a drink she's gonna get so many
tinder messages
[Music]